ah Dan there will be 10 episodes 10
episodes bestiality B just remember the
episode of cannibalism childhood friend
I will say with the bestiality thing we
didn't want to do it the fans demanded
it I will shoot this rock I will hurt
this tree I will hunt this beast up the
land and put my feet in there yes the
network with leg alright you've shown
the data sit we're numb we need more to
shock us yeah yeah most of your religion
said we couldn't do it we did it in a
classy way
yeah well and also just we're doing a
bit there's not bestiality I'm just
gonna moment I feel like after that you
know first episode of season 3 is sort
of like you know getting everything back
to somewhat of a normal kind of rhythm
with a few exceptions you know Jerry and
bath are sort of splitting and that's
gonna that's gonna add a different kind
of flavor to this to the seasons do you
write to the guest star like do you
think like oh my god I gotta get you
know whoever and and then write a
character for that person I feel like we
will sort of have a dream person in mind
and like you know you kind of like
you'll sort of have someone in your mind
some but in your minds you know like
those dream yeah yeah I mostly not
though I think sometimes not about you
about the special
picture somebody like you might picture
Ian McShane or something because you're
writing somebody who's like Al
Swearengen in Deadwood you know and so
then maybe you might go well we've kept
thinking about that character so see if
he and McShane's available yeah yeah Ian
McShane is not available
[Music]
[Laughter]
he wouldn't comprehend them I've dwelt
among the humans their entire culture is
built around their penises it's funny to
say they're small it's funny to say
they're big have been at parties where
humans have held bottles pencils
thermoses in front of themselves and
called out Hey look at me and mr.
so-and-so dick I've got such-and-such
for a penis for sure this person I think
also Nathan fielder right kinda a little
bit no I think it's safe to say summer
has a story where her or her adolescent
body image issues take a sci-fi turn
yeah even what do you have in common
with Tricia lang a mutual love of French
cinema the belief that a carbon tax was
the only viable solution to climate
change
very special episode hey Rick Sanchez
this episode was a really important one
if you have body dysmorphia please call
the body dysmorphia dot-com ww hundreds
more fear spoilers they're basically
going to keep saying your body's fine
it's the only help Mama's coming baby
Mama's coming and she chairs the poor
kitties might as well just scream this
just put it on screen is Bahamas on the
phone but speeches are for campaigning
now is the time for action hey everybody
new bonus interview before the season
finale drops so they dropped this along
with a bunch of material that didn't
make it into the video where Dan
Harmon's talking about stuff that's
coming in the future in season 4
episodes so if you are finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'll be doing weekly Rick
and Morty videos during the offseason
while we wait for those season 4
episodes to get here so the most
important stuff first
Dan Harmon makes it sound like that
actually will deliver 14 episodes for
season 4 and they say that they were
originally intended to do 14 episodes
for season 3 a lot of you in the
comments were really blown away with the
thought that episode 10 is the final
episode for season 3 because there were
a number of articles quoting the number
14 that supposedly something that Dan
Harmon said in another interview but
then you know come to season 3 and
there's only 10 so what happened to
those other four so he says that was
mostly his fault and the time that it
took to get things going so if you
really have said that there were only 10
this season then just blamed the delay
but that wasn't what they intended if
you saw that last finale video I posted
the other day I included a clip where he
talks about how they tried to
re-engineer their creative process to
get Rick and Morty out even faster for
season 4 he's quoted in this new
interview as saying that what they're
gonna do is they're gonna start with the
10 scripts that they would normally do
prove that they have the extra time go
to Adult Swim and say we
do for more episodes for this season
meeting as I speculated in my last video
that they've already started riding
their season 4 scripts because the
writers are in the writers room right
now so of course they have to be working
on season 4 but when you're asking about
how long before we get to the season 4
premiere
I'm guessing it's gonna be sometime
around next summer close to when they
premiered season 3 it takes about six
months to animate episodes so they can
get most of their scripts out by the end
of this year they can actually get
episodes on the air by next summer at
the latest so it just depends on how
long it takes them to finish writing all
the episodes but he also said a couple
of the things that'll figure into my
bonus videos between seasons because he
says that they don't plan things out too
far ahead they don't want to paint
themselves into a corner so like during
the GRE episode where you go into Rick's
mind and you see the picture of bird
person on the pedestal they don't know
exactly what that means like they're not
intending it to be okay bird person is
going to show up in X episode because we
saw him on this pedestal here it's just
that bird person will eventually come
back and they haven't completely figured
it out yet so when you're making
theories just keep that in mind it's
always helpful to know what their
creative processes and like what they
intended when they did certain things
especially the big twist like evil Morty
but they did say they be going back to
the Citadel so even if they don't
resolve evil Morty in the finale they
will follow up with the next season so
it's not like they're gonna wait three
seasons to go back to evil Morty but for
all of you hoping that Rick and Morty
stays on the air for a long long time he
does say that they really love making
this and they'll just keep going and
going and going but they don't know
what's gonna happen in five seasons or
six seasons he says one of the only
things that they're never going to do
like time travel for instance is explain
why Rick is rigged so even though you
get little shades of that like they hint
at things there's never gonna be an
episode where they just flat-out say
this is exactly why he does all the
things that he does which i think is
part of the brilliance of the character
so I'll be posting some new rick and
morty later this week I'll say
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner Isaiah bboy please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there's a new round in this video too
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber
leave a comment on the video you can
click here to rewatch that finale video
and listen to Dan Harmon talk about
season four and you can click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]